aujourd'hui se trouvent sur ce world are
ds game 3 impressionnant c'est le menu
c'est le [ __ ] de menus que c'est déjà
le jeu en fait et pourquoi je joue à ce
jeu sans déconner je pourrais pas plutôt
me faire un café me poser tranquille sur
le canapé quoi moi je pense que le mieux
c'est de faire une nouvelle partie
attentes autant je sens bien la coupe et
son lapsus là haut j'ai tout analysé je
pense avoir compris maintenant
non ça comme aux caisses partie au mais
non mais
mais non mais je suis level 1 à 2 quoi
il pourrait marquer énorme merde que
vincent offrir le même effet oh mais
sans surprise sans surprise pourquoi je
dis or comme la lybie mieux c'est bon je
me suis rangé attends attends mais je
contourne la cage rouge est absent je ma
ville
nous avons clé et donc aptes à fois la
droite au nom comme vous avez pu me
faire ça sans déconner mais vous
connaissez pas mais bon en armant on a
un peu de respect pour autrui et ma foi
ça se dégage et là je fonds mais voilà
je me demande ce que c'est que ce truc
vert effectivement au plat au plat et et
là je suis paralysée là je sais plus
quoi faire je vois pas du tout nord
attendait mais on peut pas au pire
maintenant à presque soit plus patient
es tu me dis pas quoi faire un jeune
cubain yes attend le qatarien fait quoi
il ya huit ans au caire tchèque pas été
gênant mais c'est des trucs je veux pas
quand je vais sortir de ce superbe bébé
c'est bon j'analysais oh [ __ ] hop au
[ __ ] [ __ ] ans
oui à ce qu'on pouvait lui un goût de
good aux gens ça j'en ai rien à faire on
est bien là on se baigne dans un liquide
vers un peu plus haut
c'est tellement bourg de réussir le
niveau 1 b 2 ap l'été de merde mais pas
trop qu'est ce que c'est que cette porte
dorée je n'en sais rien tant une
question au lait à ok ça ouvre une porte
du niveau d'avant on attendait les mecs
je vais pas lui au niveau 6 pour revenir
aux niveaux rare pour prendre la petite
tache verte indique de façon c'est un
jeune vicieux non je m'en fous non faut
que je reprenne les clés mais je les
avais pourquoi un [ __ ] du coup je
pense que je revienne dans le niveau
d'avant et là faut que j'aille en bas
j'espère ou en eau ou les deux un petit
oubli sur vicieux j'y vais au feeling
voilà apparemment ça marche pas trop je
savais que tu me lasserai pas pu
tintaine sale tête par rapport aux
autres ma grand mère fait mieux que ça
alors déjà tu vas te calmer tout de
suite à eau pour tourner en eau et yes
monga pièce mamma mia mamma mia
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc est
alors on va enfin savoir monsieur est
quand même très grande histoire derrière
ce jeu well and that the deacon
donc j'ai donc avait une histoire très
passionnante on verrait alors au-dessus
à quoi au nom mais ça c'est petit truc
qui te fait rage et au voyage avec lui
j'ai dit oh non non non non non non non
non non mais non non non non donc quoi
yes yes à ça c'était mieux y aura pas
mal autour allez on y va c'est la fête
aux gifles à oô la petite esquisse et au
maître de kung-fu qu'il n'a pris donc
ait had immédiate 1ier heureusement
toujours bien peu des fois fils de chien
50 morts déjà à des tétouan [ __ ] tacle
est à nouveau voilà qu'est ce qu'elle
ouvre non mais mais c'était n'utilise
que ça ouvert en fait non non mais
personne ne s'attendait à ce que je me
prenne seront là je te banni de ce jeu
tout de suite
ah mais c'est bon j'ai quand même la clé
c'est bon tu peux rester le respect
envers autrui je vous en parlais tout à
l'heure bon attention attention la joie
sur mon visage la joie sur mon visage
voilà ça c'est la joie ok et la norme
ans assez ouvert voilà
et maintenant y aille j'approuve ce
message j'approuve voilà bon discours
vos discours aux hausses étaient juste
c'était juste mais c'était bon et ça je
m'en fous c'est tranquille trop haut au
jeu m'impressionne là mais vraiment les
gens 146 morts
oh là là je le sois un peu moins bien
quoi oui mon gars yes yes
voilà maintenant j'ai douze pièces et le
jeu est tellement déterminé mais je suis
content et si ça vous pose un problème
et ben voilà c'est un tournant suis là
je pense et revenir où j'étais bien joué
lucas la mairie la famille à taussat ans
commença le temps d'en haut le progrès
était présent au progrès étaient
présents merde pose peu et c'est reparti
parce qu'on adore ça à pita j'avais
oublié le pire du pire c'est que je suis
quoi c'est bien que ça m'a fait de
réussir à 100 tonnes
quand tu joues à ce jeu la musique reste
seul ami mais je n'ai pas de musique
dans les oreilles
ce qui fait que je n'ai pas d'amis ce
qui fait que je suis seul au monde mais
à a
qu'est ce qu'on a en bas je t'en supplie
jeunes paroisse grise laisse pas passer
c'est avec gm on peut le dire mais je ne
suis pas heureusement je suis heureux
aujourd'hui de vous annoncer qu'on a
passé un couloir et qu'il en reste six
sur dix ans aujourd'hui qui nous reste
sept couloir 7 la clé est à nous j'ai un
petit espoir que la clint les portes sur
chacune des deux autres clés mais ceci
n'est pas possible bien sûr une kent et
les porte pas le cas les boules en
faites quoi se déplacer une sorte de
flou de mouvement autour d'elle est en
fait qu il ya énormément de boules bas
ça me fait mal à la bouche comme anodin
non vous n'êtes pas à l'aise là pour moi
oui mais je suis mal à l'aise pour moi
aussi donc ça tombe bien bien s'entendre
ok là je peux pas faire là je peux pas
faire je parais moyen âge par les moyens
mais la belle dame et des maillys des
super moyens
alors là on lâche le père je t'ai pas
comprend rien mais je pense qu'on peut
faire un truc comme ça nos ya combien de
niveau level 2 c3 [ __ ] mais si on va
jusqu'à z4 on est mal qu un bordel on
entend plein pas temps plein pas luca
luca temps plein pas l'udc est en
flammes par j'essaie d'analyser et voilà
très grosse analyses ont vu un bas
d'ailleurs je devenir chimiste au
laboratoire à je perds mes moyens
vous assurez non pourquoi d'un coup
j'étais sur mon ordi ceux d'un jeu des
stars qu'on puisse vous m'avez
conseiller mais par centaines ce jeu et
ne me dites pas que c'était pour me
faire plaisir a quitté pour me tenir au
courant de l'actualité du jeu vidéo que
c'est faux je ne vous crois pas c'est
pour m'infliger une souffrance éternelle
j'ai des cicatrices sur le corps par
butt je me sens mal tous les soirs quand
je me couche
les seuls mots je me sens bien c'est
quand je réussis mais ça dépend mois
plus tard voilà je donne mon petit
secret en fait mon bras et dans le vide
mais cheikh quand je m'appuie son bureau
voyez plus ma taille du coup je fais
comme ça tout le monde est satisfait
enfin sauf moi en fait on va juste pour
vous permettre la musique ni qu'elle a
acquis quitte à en avoir marre autant
aura jusqu'au bout mais des mecs faut
s'inspirer d'accords iframe [ __ ] moi
je t'explique dans l'eucharistie le
regard remplace pedro en quoi un god oh
non mais attends mec mais la chanson là
il est tellement un corps tu as
l'impression que les roues ça devient
des supers méchants mais gare mais
hardcore et coup alors que non ça reste
des violons tous pourris mais qui te tue
quand même butin non hashtag tristesse